elle assure elle même la visite valérie
pecresse présentent le nouveau siège de
la région ile de france au revoir les
beaux quartiers parisiens où les deux
mille agents étaient dispersés sur 11
sites différents
bonjour saint-ouen en seine-saint-denis
où les services sont regroupés dans cet
immeuble de bureaux de sept étages à
deux pas de la station mairie de
saint-ouen un déménagement très
symbolique
il n'y a pas un bon et un mauvais côté
du périphérique on revient on vient dans
un quartier populaire la région centre
dans les quartiers populaires et dans
leur réalité
ensuite un avantage économique
évidemment 9 millions d'euros par an
d'économies sur les loyers c'est
beaucoup et sur la durée et bien ça nous
permet de redonner cet argent en aide
sociale en investissement pour les
lycéens en investissements dans les
transports d'ici fin février ils seront
1400 agents à investir le nouveau siège
du conseil régional
ils vont découvrir un bâtiment lumineux
et spacieux avec de nombreux points de
restauration ils vont surtout prendre
possession de leurs nouveaux espaces de
travail en mode open space désormais ils
vont devoir aussi s'habituer à des temps
de transport pour certains rallonger la
région a donc décidé de leur permettre
de télétravail et on va proposer à 80 %
des agents de télétravail et un ou deux
jours par semaine
on en a 6 ans qui depuis janvier sont
passés en télétravail donc ça veut dire
que vraiment les dossiers on les fait
plus tôt à la maison et quand on vient
sans trois ans c'est vraiment pour pour
se rencontrer pour échanger pour faire
des réunions de travail etc
ce déménagement se fera en deux temps un
bâtiment est en construction en face de
l'hôtel de région il abritera le futur
hémicycle où les élus votent les grandes
décisions